il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique du mercredi il sera question
comme chaque semaine d'environnement
avec mélanie poquet bonsoir mélanésiens
floral alors ce soir nous parlons aussi
recherche puisque vous êtes allés à la
rencontre d'un chercheur qui vient
d'être primé par le cnrs le centre
national de la recherche scientifique
alors ce chercheur s'appelle olivier all
bran il travaille au lsce le laboratoire
des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement qu'il a intégré en 2008
le lse est une unité mixte de recherche
du cea le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives du
cnrs et de l'université versailles saint
quentin
olivier evrard travaillent sur le site
du cnrs à j'y suis sur yvette et il fait
partie de la promotion 2016 des
médaillés du cnrs chaque année le cnrs
récompense des chercheurs pour leurs
travaux qu'ils soient reconnus goût
prometteur olivier evrard fait partie de
la promotion de la médaille de bronze
alors au sein du laboratoire ils
travaillent sur le traçage des sédiments
et des polluants dans les rivières c'est
avant tout un travail de terrain mais
aussi d' analyses en laboratoire il
étudie l'origine des polluants leur
impact et leur persistance dans les sols
la médaille de bronze
elle récompense le premier travail d'un
chercheur je vais citer le cnrs à propos
de ces récompenses
ça fait de lui un spécialiste de talent
dans son domaine
cette récompense représente un
encouragement du cnrs à poursuivre des
recherches bien engagé et déjà fait
contre
écoutez la réaction d'olivier marc c'est
agréable d'être du cnrs donc
encourager à poursuivre les recherches
oui c'est agréable entendre après je
pense que
on fait notre métier comme come to me le
fais donc on a certains certains outils
quand on a la chance d'avoir en
laboratoire qui permet de faire des
mesures de radioactivité bas niveau on a
l'occasion d'être super réactif ce qu'on
essaye dans la mesure du possible
d'aller sur le terrain faire nos
prélèvements de lait conditionné de les
analyser d'interpréter les résultats
alors mélanie dites nous en plus sur ce
travail qui l'a amené à obtenir cette
médaille de bronze justement alors
olivier brun travaillent sur différents
niveaux de radioactivité la majeure
partie des activités du laboratoire se
passe dans un milieu environnemental
classiques comme l'île de france et le
bassin de la seine on y retrouve de la
radioactivité naturelle mais aussi de
l'artificiel qui est presque uniquement
lié aux retombées des essais
thermonucléaire atmosphérique des années
60 et de manière plus limitée des
retombées de l'accident de tchernobyl de
1986 mais olivier evrard et le fce sont
aussi amenés à faire des analyses à
l'étranger on l'écouté je pensais aussi
été l'attribution à mener a certainement
été aidée aussi par ce projet fukushima
parce que là on était vraiment dans un
cas de figure où la substance qu on
mesure tous les jours dans des
échantillons prélevés en france a été
émise en grande quantité à un endroit
c'était quand même un cas de figure
c'est unique d'avoir un événement qui se
produit et de pouvoir comprendre à la
fois la redistribution ces polluants un
contexte post accidentelle mais aussi
d'avoir un cas unique d'études de ce qui
se passe même en condition va dire
normal alors pour rappel l'accident de
fukushima i lieu il ya à peine plus de
cinq ans c'était le 11 mars 2011 au
japon
audi vieille brard et le lsc eux sont
partis sur le terrain dès l'automne 2011
soit tout juste six mois après
l'accident il s'agisse il s'agissait de
traces et la dispersion de la
contamination le long des rivières qui
draine autour du nuage de contamination
principal là que la contamination
n'était pas figé puisque les substances
radioactives se sont fixés sur les
argiles et les limons et ont suivi la
particule pour dans son cheminement dans
les rivières
est ce qu'il vous a dit à mélanie sur
quoi porterait ses prochaines recherches
alors sa prochaine étude ce sera en
nouvelle calédonie avec les mines de
nickel pour arriver aux couche de nickel
il fallait creuser ce qui a donné de la
matière très importante qui ensuite
s'est écoulé dans les rivières en
contrebas et a réduit le début de ces
rivières olivier evrard partir à étudier
la provenance de ces particules et
pourquoi pas être distingué d'une
nouvelle médaille du cnrs en tout cas
pour ce qui est celle de la médaille de
bronze
il la recevra officiellement à l'automne
prochain et on lui adresse toutes nos
félicitations merci beaucoup mélanine on
vous retrouve mercredi prochain pour une
nouvelle chronique